ああああああああ
パイ投げ皆さんしたことありますでしょうかこれたのあれだの端稲城セットっていう
オモチャなんですけど
ああこういうタイプですくれみたいになっててありがたいお皿が空いています
構成は海ができるとおおーー
こういう感じですねスパイダーげっていうことがあるんですけども
2の速度キャットも面白くないと思ったんですよこんなさらにねくれるのっけでさあ
どんなということででも全然楽しめないと思ったわけでしょ
楽しくについて今回はピッチングは水を準備しましたの出会いであるよ
ピッチングマシーンでだけれどもっと楽しいんじゃないかと思ってパイの差が時速
160キロで空を飛ぶわけですよ
面白いでしょパイ投げを160キロで行ったら摩れでもそれと思うので今回はちょっと
にピッチングマシーンでねパイ投げをやってねそれぐらい楽しいかやっていると思い
ます
ジャイ子
me
はいというでキッチンば c の熱投もかなり速いいる
作戦としてばこれ溜まった子いないよ飛んでどういう体内を発射しようかと言いますと
難しいペーパーになりましたのハーフ
wh
いやぐらいの速度でやっていくと思いますちょっと通って言って大変なことで冊前の
部分になったよね
これからいい声で打てると思う
体内を付けて発射するかと言いますとどういう場所
されるので簡単スパイをつくってこれって何かもうちょいから前へ出てバスそのもう一
ビル2階
ゲットってファイフとってを言うぞ
car
ベンチがあった
物資会になっちゃいます特に線として手に入れます
コーラここで受け止めてもらいます
ふふわー8 a
q ですよ間にどうにセットするかといいますとそういう感じなんがガムテープ中何か
くっつけるで刺してされるボールの池を使って大変を飛ばすと
けどボールは飛んでいかないと言うカンペには仕組みでございます
こんな感じどう
いきます
このません
ああああああ
ああああああっ
それよって
うわぁ
goo ん
ああああああ
me
uh uh ee
っていうわー
re
ん
あった
tan
あ
医療が続いて算数で止まるたいと思います
そうです
同窓ないでございました
でかねがねがちょっと水この結構ゴールもになっています
鳳凰した際これ
ちょうどいい歳になりましたのでしっかり見せないから投げて当たればってなると思う
とそれはもうこのパイ運のみんじゃない方です会のボールを投げて
に使って破裂して大成功で終わりましょう
a
tee
ああああああ
dere
p 2わー
ええええええ
me
teame
rar
car
me
ああああああ
car